DC's Titans has earned a mostly positive reaction
from fans and critics, but DC Universe's flagship
series is far from perfect.
These are our picks for the five best - and
five worst - things about Titans so far.
Best: The Nuclear Family
Titans season 1 introduced villains the Nuclear
Family, who quickly established themselves
as being funny, creepy, and absolutely vicious.
The Nuclear Family of the comics were somewhat
different; they had a different origin, different
powers, and never actually locked horns with
the Titans.
Their first appearance was 1985's The Outsiders
#1, where they were actually all robots.
Despite their safe, suburban appearance, these
villains are truly brutal on the show, going
so far as putting Dove in a lengthy coma.
Thematically, they're perfect adversaries
for the Titans.
Just about all the Titans are either orphans,
runaways, or both, while the sadistic Nuclears
are a twisted parody of what society would
have us believe is a "true" family.
"Hold your f---ing' horses."
"Honey!
Language."
"Sorry."
Worst: Beast Boy's powers
Ryan Potter does a good job as Gar Logan,
a.k.a. Beast Boy.
But fans of the character have still been
frustrated by how limited his powers have
seemed so far.
In the comics, Gar can turn into just about
any kind of animal.
It doesn't matter if the animal is native
to Earth or even if it's ever existed.
Yet for all of Titans' first season, Gar only
uses his powers to change into a tiger.
"Tigers have always been my favorite, ever
since I was a kid."
The show has a justification for Gar's limited
skill set, but it still takes away from the
fun of wondering what Beast Boy will change
into next.
The situation is starting to get better, though.
In the season 2 premiere, shortly after the
Trigon-possessed Titans beat Gar to a pulp,
we see him change into a snake.
Hopefully we'll see some more variety in the
episodes to come.
Best: Jason Todd
Curran Walters first appeared as Jason Todd
- AKA the new Robin - halfway through Titans'
first season, and it wasn't clear if the young
braggart would be a regular feature.
But Jason shows up in the season 2 premiere,
and by the end of the episode he's joined
the team at Titans Tower in San Francisco.
"You're the new Robin?"
"Present and accounted for, babe."
Jason adds an unstable element to the Titans
- he's hot-blooded, doesn't respect authority,
and doesn't play well with others.
And comics readers know that he's a ticking
time bomb.
Jason was famously killed by the Joker in
the classic "Death in the Family" storyline,
returning years later as the lethal vigilante
Red Hood.
Worst: Where's the action?
Titans is pretty light on action.
And when a fight scene does kick off, it's
often a little underwhelming.
Titans is good at more grounded action, like
scenes of Dick Grayson taking on a bunch of
thugs in an alleyway.
But the team now includes a girl with demonic
powers, a boy who can change into deadly beasts,
a fighter comparable to Wonder Woman, and
a super-strong alien who can hurl energy blasts
at her foes.
So why are so many fights just simple hand-to-hand
combat?
It's rare to even see more than two or three
of the heroes fighting together.
Granted, Titans is still just a TV show, and
you can't expect big-budget special effects.
But what's the point of a superhero team-up
series if we don't get to see them all teaming
up for a giant fight?
Best: Hawk & Dove
Despite their silly costumes, the story of
Hawk and Dove has proven to be one of Titans'
most compelling arcs.
Some of the best episodes of the first season
focused on their different motives for becoming
crimefighters, Hawk's struggle with drug addiction,
and Dove's brief romance with Dick Grayson.
Hopefully we'll see more of the pair in the
second season and beyond.
Worst: An empty universe
DC's most powerful superheroes exist in the
universe of Titans, but it doesn't always
feel like it.
All the big names are sidelined, and the longer
the show goes on, the more conspicuous their
absences feel.
"Big house, it's funny that I only ever see
two of you.
It's almost like the studio couldn't afford
another X-Man."
We're already seeing the show's creative team
struggling to explain the absence of characters
from the expanded universe, and not just the
ones in capes.
In the season 2 premiere when Hawk & Dove
go to the Wayne Mansion looking for Batman,
Jason Todd has to break some bad news.
"Bruce is halfway across with the world with
the Justice League.
Alfred, too."
Wait - Alfred, too?
Why would Alfred need to go on assignment
with the Justice League?
They can't make their own tea?
Best: The season 1 finale
It may have had a frustrating cliffhanger,
but the season 1 finale was by far one of
Titans' best episodes.
Trigon subjects Dick to a nightmare vision
of his old mentor finally snapping and going
on a rampage throughout Gotham City, with
Dick being the only one who can stop him - which
he does.
Permanently.
The decision to give in to his most violent
urges puts Dick under Trigon's control.
Dick's adventure in the illusory Gotham is
an example of how Titans uses the expanded
universe to its advantage.
We only see glimpses of characters like Batman,
Joker, and Two-Face, but in this episode at
least, it's all we need to see.
Worst: That Bruce Wayne casting
The only A-list superhero we've actually seen
on Titans is Bruce Wayne, who shows up for
the first time in the season 2 premiere.
You'd be hard-pressed to challenge Iain Glen's
talent, especially after his memorable turn
as Jorah Mormont on Game of Thrones.
but it's questionable whether or not he's
right for this particular role.
For one, his American accent isn't the most
convincing thing in the world, and at 58 years
old, he also seems just a little bit too old
to be playing the Dark Knight.
Glen isn't too old to play a retired Batman.
But one who's still active with the Justice
League?
That's a stretch.
Best: Teasing Nightwing
In the comics, Dick Grayson eventually comes
out from Batman's shadow, sets his Robin costume
aside, and rebrands himself as the hero Nightwing.
As Nightwing, Dick has a darker, less Peter-Pan-esque
costume and he even eventually leaves Gotham
to find his own stomping grounds in the fictional
city of Blüdhaven.
Titans has been teasing this development since
the first season, and it seems like just a
matter of time before Dick adopts the new
duds.
Worst: Trigon's defeat
Toward the end of 2018, Titans showrunner
Greg Walker confirmed that the season 2 premiere
episode, "Trigon," was originally meant to
be the season 1 finale.
He claimed this was changed because he loved
the idea of ending the first season with a
cliffhanger and starting the next with a bang.
But after watching the episode, you might
wonder if the actual reason was because the
culmination of the story is just isn't satisfying.
In "Trigon," almost every hero besides Rachel
and Gar do nothing to contribute to the main
villain's defeat.
Most of the heroes get possessed and just
stand around, looking possessed.
Rachel insists she has to free Dick from possession
before fighting Trigon, but it's not like
she really needs his help.
How does she defeat the all-powerful demon
we've been told can destroy the universe?
She walks up to him, says something snarky,
unleashes her power, and just kind of vaguely…
wins.
How she beats him isn't really spelled out
at all.
So much for that storyline.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
shows are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.